this is just beautiful so now uh Jen
saki now you remember Jen saki uh she
was the former White House Press
Secretary the woman could not say
anything true of her life depended on it
uh well she's even now she is what
happens to her she leaves the White
House and then what do you do you get a
job she's an NBC News analyst and she
has a show I think coming out on MSNBC
but think about how fraudulent the
entire they do it right in front of our
faces you are a paid public relations
liar for an Administration that's what
your job is to do and then you get a job
analyzing the news and we're supposed to
take any of this seriously you clowns
you ridiculous abject clowns well here
she is completely contradicting Karen
Jean-Pierre they also know that crime is
a huge vulnerability for Democrats I
would say one of the biggest
vulnerabilities says the crime is a huge
vulnerability for Democrats why would
you say that so you know
um again I can't do electoral politics
from here as you know but I I kind of I
don't agree with your character
organization of what she actually said
she literally said it's a huge liability
for Democrats now what's funny is when
Jen saki was standing behind that Podium
only months ago she would have never
acknowledged that crime is a problem for
Democrats right she would try to confuse
you we've played many videos where they
tried to make it sound like Republicans
were defunding the police and actually
democrat-run cities aren't uh you know
drowning in crime can we get the number
Daphne can we get the how many people
were shot in Chicago this past weekend
can I get a death and shooting number
please uh this is what's happening
across Democrat cities we all know it
the average person knows it we spend
time we spent about 48 hours in New York
City and it it's a dump it is a dump I
loved New York City growing up my
great-grandparents lived there my
grandma lived there I lived in New York
City from 2000 to 2013. I was there
during 9 11. I absolutely loved New York
City if you can make it there you can
make it anywhere
um I gave I gave Connor the full
Seinfeld tour of the Upper West Side
showing off all the restaurants and
everything like I love New York City or
loved New York City it's a dump now it
smells like weed Everywhere You Don't
See business people that's what was
shocking we were in Midtown we we
wandered around like you don't see
people wearing suits like doing business
anymore you just see a lot of people in
hoodies and everyone smells like weed
and I'm not even against weed at some
level or certainly at a personal level
but everything smells like weed it's
dirty the you can sense like there's
that that if you just got punched in the
face on the street that nobody would
care that it just wouldn't matter and
all that stuff 38 people were shot in
Chicago uh this past weekend seven dead
uh we're not going to hear any of their
names because you can guess the color of
the skin of the shooters and the color
of the skin of the victims doesn't fit
the equation so we can't talk about that
but the point is that saki she goes from
being a liar at the White House then she
just makes more money to be a liar and a
quote analyst so if you've got a friend
that's it that watches NBC news or or
MSNBC for news you got to say to them
you got to grab them you got to grab
them by the head and you gotta you gotta
smack them and you gotta smack them
again and go what are you doing you're
getting your news from someone who is
has told you what they are they are an
activist they are they she she is a
Democrat right that's okay you could be
a there's Republican versions of all of
this too right the swamp is what the
swamp is I'm just talking about the girl
that's doing it now the idea that she
could analyze uh news for you the same
person who's been lying about the news
that like she was the chief liar for the
last year and now she's a news analyst
just absolutely incredible